there seems to be quite a lot of
negativity about the new Willow TV
series I've just watched the first two
episodes and I quite liked it ish
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
quick warning there might be a few
little spoilers if you haven't already
seen the first two episodes of Willow
but I am not reviewing it really I'm
more gonna talk about some of the
negativity I've seen regarding the new
show and just a briefing about what I
think first of all we have to mention
the dreaded woke we just have to
um there is a lesbian relationship in
this series and some people have gone oh
they're at it again here goes Disney
making another woke series
I actually say and I've said this many
times before about the woke thing look
there is a problem in Hollywood that
they try to tell us exactly how we
should live and how we should think and
blah blah blah virtue signaling I
completely get that that's a problem
it's it's bloody propaganda at the end
of the day when it overtakes the story
and propaganda has always been around as
far as there's been media and always
probably will be but in this series the
relationship is not front and center it
is a Forbidden love but no different
really than if it was a male and a
female in this role you know the
princess and a soldier somebody she's
not supposed to love especially since
he's been betrothed to another the fact
that they're two women
it's sort of there's a few little raised
eyebrows and things but it's not
overtaking the story in any way I
appreciate some people don't like this I
appreciate some people think it's a sin
but those people are stupid
in this this it's it's just part of the
story and if you say well I've just done
it because of LGBT whatever I'm sorry
but lesbian relationships do exist in
reality and our TV and television should
reflect that so no do I have a problem
with that is it woke no no
don't forget to like subscribe and share
the video with all of your other Gator
friends also you go to side
hashtrack.com for brilliant Stargate
related merch just like this you can
even buy socks and anything else you
want please also don't forget the
Sidetrack sides Channel I do loads of
little live videos and other fun stuff
all of the links are in the description
one thing I do say that I will
quite negative about this series is
about Warwick Davis now Warwick Davis is
a National Treasure I'm British I love
the man and I won't hear anything
negative said about him
accept that he's not a particularly good
actor and when he's trying to do the
whole I am wise Willow bit particularly
in the first
um episode it comes over really wouldn't
I didn't read your mind
it's just you remind me of your mother
and it's quite irritating it's actually
quite difficult to watch in places it's
like as well that there's like he's got
an earpiece and somebody's reading him
his lines he keeps having little pauses
between sentences which is when you
notice quite frustrating your brother's
alive a prisoner of the withered Crone
who dwells in immemorial city that lies
beyond the shattered sea
the fool who came to tears lean are her
servants
um but in the second episode it seems to
relax a bit more and when he actually
starts to play the willow character and
when he's not being the wise and
Powerful sorcerer because he kind of
isn't then he settles in much more and
it's much less
Troublesome other elements to the series
that I've really enjoyed so far I've
liked the little comments about like uh
we've got enough in the fellowship now
you know when they're putting their
little team together to go on the
adventure
um I like that I like that they've sort
of poked fun a little bit that people
are going to make in comparisons to the
Lord of the Rings this is swords and
sorcery
um so it's going to have little
comparisons and they make fun of that a
little bit
but I am going to say I do think
honestly a lot of people have sort of
gone quite negative on Willow because
maybe their expectations are a little
bit tight my expectations what I want
from this series are reasonably low you
know I'm not expecting massive battle
scenes I'm not expecting high drama I'm
expecting a fun silly at times TV series
with some magic and some sorcery I'm not
expecting this series to take itself too
seriously and to be honest we shouldn't
take it too seriously Disney haven't
spent a billion pounds making it so I
really don't think that we just need to
start worrying about that a couple of
other things though I have really liked
about this I do like the willow
character I do like how they've sort of
Twisted it a little bit in the beginning
he's sort of the character that he wants
to be he is the great wise powerful
Sorcerer And The Queen to be honest bats
him down quite quickly when he wants to
take a Laura and wants to train it he
basically says you're the bravest man
I've ever met but you're no great
Sorcerer And you never will be and to be
honest that hurts Willow's feelings and
he has a bit of a baby strop but later
in the second episode particularly we
get to see the willow that we should
have would expect from the movie that he
is still quite insecure he is not as you
know he isn't the great wise sorcerer
that he wants to be he is still the
willow from the movie is my point and I
kind of like how they did that little
flip in the character between the two
First episodes I've got to say as well
the villains that attacked the castle in
the first episode were bloody brilliant
I don't know why that big guy with a
cage on his head doesn't take the cage
off
but it looked terrifying the little
wizard dude was great and the character
and Commander Valentine the actor Ralph
innocent that plays him has the greatest
voice he does a lot of like car adverts
here in the UK there's a voice over for
them because it's a brilliant deep voice
he was in Game of Thrones and loads of
other things over the years his
character again is brilliant a brilliant
villain
um I really looking forward to seeing
where that goes at the end of the second
episode again spoiler if you haven't
seen it we do see him grab a Laura and
take a
um just as she realizes or just as her
magic starts to work I do also like that
they've set up a couple of things for
the rest of the series in particular the
Mad Madigan storyline now obviously Val
kilma could not appear in this series
he's still very unwell
but they have sort of explained where he
is but in an intriguing way that doesn't
give away too much I mean they could
have just killed him he went on the
adventure to get the magical armor and
he failed he died but then we have a
throwaway comment by the character
fraxis who happens to say he found the
armor so we don't know where madikan is
right now but he may not actually be
dead again if they weren't going to do
something with this character at some
point in the series they would have just
killed him off wouldn't they or just
said he was missing Praxis wouldn't have
made that comment so we can see
hopefully them do something very clever
with the Mad modicum character
I have to also say though there is a lot
of CGI in this series that would have
been very expensive this CGI where they
make the characters younger
they actually did a pretty good job with
Willow much better than they did and the
Marvel series did with sort of She-Hulk
or a couple of other things 100 better
than the first Star Wars where we saw um
Luke younger you know it's more like on
par with the second time we saw Luke
younger I do think it's a mix of sort of
makeup and special effects those sort of
things do look a lot better when they
blend them
um and also they just do little things
like they make sure that Willow's got a
beard to you know help cover up the
mouth as much as possible these little
tricks help sell the bit and for me
worked really well my expectations are
reasonable I just want a popcorn sit
down enjoy bit of magic bit of Sword
Play series I don't expect anything more
than that and to be honest Willow
delivers Willow at the end of the day
does exactly what it says on the tin
but guys get into the comments tell me
what you think of the new Willow Series
in the first two episodes any good have
you enjoyed it or have you disliked it
some people have really disliked it um
I'd love to hear from you guys as well
I'd love to hear why
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe but the Bell notification
it really helps us out also if you want
to become a fully fledged side tracker
hit the join button as always guys
please stay safe and I'll see you next
time
thank you
foreign